và đình chính trong lình tổng gì kè sòn.
Giân chung thập bình nhấn của phay loạn ngà,
dự lất kiểm nhiệm 8.5 ngàn thích lập đảng lâu đầu truyền.
Tổng viết đảng lâu đầu truyền,
trụ tịch Quốc vũ trở tiền kìm trong ơn.
Ngay mong mời thân mời đã có cố hội đầm với trụ tịch đảng nước ngà thung nhất.
Phó trụ tịch hội đau ăn ninh liên bằng ngà,
ông đi mi truyền Mẹ Pé đẹp.
Tại cố hội đầm, ông kìm trong ơn khả miền,
trên thăm gộ Mẹ Pé đáp thế hiện sự ủng hộ và đòn kết bứng chắc của đảng nước ngà thung nhất và nhìn dừng ngà.
Đối với sự nghiệp của đảng lâu đầu truyền và nhé dạ chú tiền.
Ông miền mạnh,
trên thăm sẽ là cơ hội quan trọng đi mở giống và phát triển quan hệ chú tiền ngà.
Thêm quan hệ lúc tác chiến lực toàn diện và lịch miền bứng chắc.
Về phần miền,
ông Mẹ Pé đáp trụ biệt,
tổng đúng nha gần là đi miệp utiền.
Lánh ra cao sự phát triển quan diện của quan hệ giả nớt.
Và tiền tự rằng về thúc lệ quan hệ với chều tiền là rất quan trọng.
Ông Mẹ Pé đáp khẳng Rị
Cám kê sẽ nấu lực hơi nữa để tăng cường cho lối và hợp tác giữa hai đảng bã khú ra.
Cũng tại khu hộ đam,
hai bên đã thảo lận với các kí hội dài ăn.
Nhằm tăng cường hình mới có cuộc tiếp súc và hợp tác giữa đảng lâu đầu truyền.
Và đảng nước nha thung nhất,
cũng như cháu hội quan điểm với tỉnh yên của tế và khu hộ của đâm.